my name is ko Strout and today I hope to
convince you why we should be thinking
about software performance as a shape
and not as a number so first just a
little bit about me I'm currently a
software engineer at light step where
I'm working on building tools that help
developers understand the performance of
complex distributed systems these are
currently mostly focused around
distributed tracing in my past life I
got a PhD from UC Berkeley my PhD
dissertation focused on understanding
performance of large-scale distributed
systems focusing specifically on
large-scale data analytics frameworks
like Apache spark I did some work on
understanding sparks performance today
and found some surprising things that
went against conventional wisdom around
performance bottlenecks and spark and I
also did some work thinking about how we
could re architect these large-scale
systems to make it easier for users to
understand performance I'm also a
committer and PMC member for Apache
spark and my work on spark has focused
on optimizing performance of the
scheduler and maintaining the course
scheduler code I think throughout all of
these projects the thing that has most
interested me is thinking about how you
can take these systems that are very
complex and distill out the sort of
simplest most essential parts to help
the people using them understand why
they're behaving the way that they are
so in this talk I'll be talking about
performance of distributed systems I
hope you walk away with this talk with a
sense of some of the tools that you
could use that would be most helpful to
understanding how these systems behave
I'll start by talking about what's going
on how you can measure symptoms in your
system and I'll argue that percentiles
are not enough that you need to look at
performance as a shape by using
histograms to understand what's going on
then I'll talk about the next step
looking at why behaviors are happening
once you understand that they're there
and I'll argue that the biggest problem
here is reducing the search space that
there's too much data right now and the
most important thing that you need to do
is to reduce that data to find the parts
that are most important and then finally
I'll wrap up by talking about
observability as a whole and how these
earlier two parts of the talk drive a
new scorecard when you're thinking about
what's important for observability tools
so first what's going on I want to talk
about what happens when developers want
to understand the performance that's
being provided by their sister
this might be understanding the
performance that's experienced by end
users or it might be understanding the
performance of some internal system is
this internal system providing the
service level objectives that it's
promised to the other services that
depend on it
so we'll walk through a history of how
folks have thought about this over the
last decade or so
so back in 2002 folks were starting to
run things on the cloud and what a
typical app might look like is that
there was a monolith running on bare
metal somewhere and the way that we
thought about performance was that we
looked at average response latency over
time this graph looks kind of boring the
average is flat you can barely see it
it's around a millisecond here at time
is progressing from left to right so now
is on the right side and using average
response latency was based on a couple
of assumptions the first was that the
latency was normally distributed or
something like that and that was
important because it meant that when you
were looking at the average you were
essentially seeing the whole behavior of
your system you were assuming that the
behavior was kind of clustered around
this one number and if there was some
problem you would see the average moving
and that would be reflected on this
graph that shows you the average now by
about 10 years later in 2012 the
landscape had changed and now what
applications typically looked like was a
monolith but that was talking to a bunch
of managed services that it depends on
so here my monolith is that big gray box
and it's talking to a bunch of other
services that fan out to a bunch of
servers those ones highlighted in yellow
are the ones that need to respond to
fulfill my request now if you start
thinking about why average latency
doesn't work anymore you can ask
yourself what the response time for this
service is going to be it may be
tempting to think it well it's just the
average of all the components but if you
think about this for a minute you'll see
that the response time is actually going
to be the worst case for any of these
components typically your service can't
respond until the slowest thing that it
depends on it's finished so as a result
the tail response time of these sub
services becomes a lot more important
just to belabor this point for a minute
if you imagine that each one of these
servers that you're depending on has one
millisecond average latency so it's
usually pretty fast but it has one
second 99th percentile latency so 1% of
the time it takes a second or more to
respond
back when you just used maybe one of
these services this latency distribution
is exactly what your service would
provide 1% of the requests would take
more than a second which feels like
maybe it's okay on the other hand if you
use a hundred of these services then
suddenly the tail response time for the
things you depend on is the thing that
drives the performance of your end
service if you use a hundred of them 63%
of the requests will take greater than
or equal to a second for that reason
people started carrying a lot more about
tail response time they would typically
measure something like 99th percentile
response latency here along the bottom
there's a time series for that same
service that I showed earlier where the
average was that kind of boring flatline
you could barely see and now when we're
looking at the 99th percentile response
latency you can see a lot more it's
going on now there are still a bunch of
assumptions underlying this number
essentially we're still assuming that
the latency distribution has a single
behavior that there's this one kind of
bump if you look at the histogram and
that we when we're looking at the 99th
percentile we're seeing one side of that
so now we're caring about the tail
performance more but you're still making
this assumption that you're kind of
seeing the whole behavior of your system
by just looking at a single number now
fast forward a couple more years now
we're in 2018 and what applications
typically look like is there's probably
still some monolith somewhere that has a
bunch of the functionality but it's
relying on an increasingly large number
of microservices to do its job and the
reason why this changes the way we think
about performance is because there are
now a lot more behaviors that can happen
in your system going back to that
assumption that the latency distribution
has one behavior that's very rarely the
case when you have all of these services
that are acting together to serve
requests so here are a couple of
examples of the latency histograms of
various parts of our internal system of
micro-services we didn't pick these
distributions to look weird this was
sort of a random sampling we took up a
bunch of our internal services we were
actually looking to see if we could find
any that looked normal and you can see
that none of these services really look
like anything close to normal just a
reminder of what you're looking at when
you're looking at a histogram along the
x-axis is late
see so faster is on the left side that's
good slower is on the right side that's
bad and then the y axis here is count so
how many things happened I think it's
always important to remember this
because we're all so accustomed to
looking at time series graphs we're
usually higher is bad but when you're
looking at a histogram remember that
things further to the right are bad so
this bottom left histogram performance
actually seems okay most of the stuff is
pretty fast around 100 microseconds I
know it's hard to see the axes out there
but then these other histograms you're
seeing much more varied behavior like
the top left one has these kind of two
clusters of behavior
one group of requests is really fast at
a couple of microseconds and then
there's this other group that's taking a
couple of seconds and if you tried to
characterize that top left histogram by
any one number you can start to see
pretty quickly why it wouldn't be very
representative of what's actually
happening like if you looked at the
median or the average you might end up
with some number that's in between those
two modes of behavior that actually
isn't describing what any of the
requests in your system are actually
seeing so to talk about another example
of this this is a problem that all
returned to you throughout this talk
where I was trying to debug some user
reported issues where we were hearing
that one of the pages on our software
was loading too slowly so here what you
can see is the median latency was fast
it was around 500 milliseconds it's hard
to see that line around the along the
bottom there but it wasn't moving much
but there were a couple of these cases
where the 99th percentile was really
slow like this one circled time the 99th
percentile was taking 17 point 7 seconds
but here at this point when I was on
call it was hard for me to understand
how bad of a problem this was like what
was actually happening between these
percentiles and how worried should I be
about how about the performances if I
look at the latency histogram with
what's going on it was a lot clearer to
see just as a reminder the latency is
along the x-axis so slower is to the
right and what I can see now is that
there are these sort of distinct
clusters of behavior there's some
requests that are being served very
quickly there's a big cluster that's
around a few hundred milliseconds so
those ones are fine those are still fast
enough but there are these two slower
clusters or
a couple of seconds and a couple of tens
of seconds and those really are a
problem and are things that I should
look into and you can get much more here
from looking at the histogram than you
could get by just looking at that time
series so with current systems these
high fidelity latency histograms are
important to measure because they reveal
these distinct performance behaviors now
it might be tempting to think there's
okay there's a bunch of different
behaviors can we just use more time
series like could we use a bunch of
different time series graphs for each of
the possible behaviors that could be
happening and the problem is here if you
have this very unscientific graph
looking at the number of micro-services
and the way those sort of combine into a
number of behaviors the number of
distinct behaviors grows combinatorially
with the number of different micro
service phases that you have if you
think about sort of a network of
micro-services there's a different
behavior for each service that's talking
to each other service depending on how
slow each service is and it's very
difficult to capture these all with
individual time series whereas if you
look at a histogram you can very clearly
see these sort of distinct clusters of
behavior that describe your system so
today the thing that is important to
measure is to measure these high
fidelity latency histograms now one
tricky part about visual in history
lysing histograms that i'll just talk
about briefly is it's non-trivial to
think about how to visualize a histogram
over time when we wanted to look at a
percentile over time we look at a normal
time series graph and time is along the
x-axis but you may have noticed that
when we started to look at the histogram
we lost the dimension of time now we're
just looking at a snapshot of what was
happening at a particular instance so
there's some cool examples of how folks
have visualized these histograms over
time this is something called a joy plot
where here you've graphed the histogram
a bunch of times
distinctly sort of separated by the y
axis so here time is moving along the y
axis and you have this kind of 3d
representation of the histograms and so
this this left one in black is one that
we did for some for a latency
distribution in our own system where you
can see some changes happening over time
where there seemed to be more outliers
earlier and we're losing some of those
outliers but I think for folks who are
interested in observability or in
visualization this is sort of an
interesting question
that's not totally solved as if you want
to look at a histogram over time what is
the most effective way of doing that and
is kind of stacking them up like this
showing you enough data the one on the
right is sort of a cool example looking
at global warming over time and you can
see how the histograms of temperatures
wiggle around a bunch but there's a
clear movement to the right so to return
to this question of what's happening in
my system hopefully I've convinced you
that averages are less useful than
percentiles and percentiles are much
less useful than latency histograms
there are a couple of other things about
measuring today's systems that makes
doing so complicated so the another
issue is that you need to measure
different dimensions there's typically
some variability and the data and the
only way to understand that variability
is by breaking the data down into the
different dimensions that explain that
so as one example here's one graph of
some metric over time let's say that
it's latency and in this case the metric
is completely described by the Machine
that the particular system was running
on so here once I've split the data by
Machine you can see that there's this
one machine that describes all of the
variability in the graph now there's
this word that has sort of come into
vogue in the last couple of years which
is cardinality and what this word means
is just the number of different values
for one dimension so here what makes
this measurement difficult is that
sometimes these dimensions become things
that have very high cardinality where
there's a lot of different values and in
order to understand your system you need
to break up the data to see how each of
these values performs differently so
this was one example talking about
machine ID where the cardinality was the
number of machines in the system this
one may seem more doable like there are
some number of machines and it's
probably reasonable to have metrics per
machine but if you think about some
other important ways to split your data
it becomes clear that the number the
sheer number of values is hard for
metric systems to handle usually once
cardinality gets into the sort of
hundreds it's hard to track these
metrics separately so another common one
that's frequently very useful is user ID
and here the cardinality is the number
of users in the system which you can
imagine quickly becomes pretty large but
it's often a very important way of
describing your data so this is another
example from our internal system where
there's this call update span group
statistics
that's kind of critical to ingesting the
data for our system and here the latency
histogram is showing me that there's a
couple of different behaviors going on
there's some that are very fast and then
there's a bunch that are quite a bit
slower and in this case I can describe a
lot of the variability in the data if I
just separate it by customer
hyrum I've added a search term for a
particular big customer whose name I've
rejected and you can see that this big
customer has calls that are consistently
slower and then if you look at some of
our smaller customers their calls are
typically faster so this has helped me
to understand what's going on and in
this case to understand how important
this problem is if the bad behavior is
mostly happening for our big customers
it's probably the ones that we care
about more and they're fort worth
looking into so the problem with
cardinality is some of these values are
really useful but some of the values
with high cardinality are not very
useful like one common example that we
see in our customers data is that
they'll have some tag for the deadline
of a request that so that tag will be
something like the number of
milliseconds in epoch time when the
request expires and if you start to
think about the cardinality of this
value that's the number of unique
milliseconds that have elapsed which
starts to become a pretty big number but
the problem is it's also not actually
useful like it's pretty rare that it's
useful to group by each of these
individual deadlines to see what the
response time is when the key challenge
here is that it's pretty hard to
convince developers to only add tags
that are useful someone probably finds
this deadline useful for something but
it's hard to restrict the way that folks
use these metric systems to keep them
from adding these things so it's crucial
that the metric systems can handle these
high cardinality tags even in cases
where they may not be particularly
useful but where they still have very
high cardinality it's pretty hard to
separate the ones that are useful from
the ones that aren't so to recap I want
to go through some of the things that
are important for us to be able to
measure the system the first is the
statistical precision now with the
complexity of current systems it's
important to have a precise histogram
rather than just a couple of numbers to
try and summarize the data the second is
cardinality if systems impose
cardinality limits it becomes much more
difficult to understand
how you can describe the variance in the
data another thing that's important is
the volume or sampling limits of the
system so here's an example where in our
internal product we decided to try
reducing the number of histogram buckets
from 200 which was the default to 40
which we thought 40 different buckets
seems like it should be enough to
describe a lot of data and what you can
see is that you pretty quickly lose the
usefulness of this histogram what used
to be this sort of distinct shapes now
looks like kind of a blob and is no
longer very useful so it's important
that the system can handle high volume
and does so without doing too much
sampling without losing the fidelity of
the data then there's two other
dimensions that are important that
people usually don't think about until
they realize that their system doesn't
have them and then they feel sad
the first is freshness how quickly does
data appear so if you look at a timeline
where this is now your system almost
never provides data right up until now
there's some gap between the current
time and the data that you can view in
the metric system and if you read some
of the old Google work about they have
this paper called dapper about
distributed tracing and one problem with
Jabbar was that they used a bunch of
analytics tools to analyze the data
afterwards and while that data was
really useful a lot of it wasn't
available until sort of hours after
things had happened which really limited
the usefulness of those tools for
debugging and firefighting situations
what we found is that this freshness
often needs to be on the order of sort
of tens of seconds for it to be useful
when people are trying to use it to
debug an outage and then the other
important time dimension is the horizon
how long is the data kept for and it's
usually useful to have a few days or
maybe a few weeks of data it's pretty
rare that anyone cares about data that
happened a couple of months or a couple
of years ago so if you just take a step
back and look at all these properties I
think the important thing to see here is
that when you're doing measurement what
you really want is more data you want
this data with high fidelity you don't
want it to be too heavily sampled you
want to be able to look at all of the
different dimensions of the data even
when it has high cardinality and you
want it faster and for a longer horizon
so that was about what's going on now
let's shift to talking about why it's
happening and in thinking about this I
think we'll see the sort of opposite
and that looking at what's going on it
was interesting to see as much data as
possible but to understand why it's
happening what we actually want is a
system that helps us reduce the data to
see only the things that are useful so
to go back to that example of why is the
page load slow what I was able to
identify before is that there were a
couple of different clusters of behavior
but what I don't know yet is why those
things are actually occurring so let me
walk through a sort of typical debugging
workflow that I'm guessing sounds
familiar to many folks in the audience
um this is certainly something that I've
done before and that we hear from a lot
of our customers who are using various
metrics tools so typically what happens
as folks first look at some metrics
maybe they got a page because some
metric is too high or maybe they were
just looking at some dashboard to
understand the performance of the system
and they've identified that something is
wrong and then they go in spot check
some logs or traces I'm and then for the
most important part of this workflow the
sort of prayer where they hope that they
find the right log or the right trace
that will give them this kind of aha
moment that tells them what was going on
with all of those slow requests so to
talk about an example of this again this
is that one slow page load and sometimes
those moments of prayers kind of don't
pan out and you get stuck and then the
thing about engineers is they're really
great at coming up with explanations of
things so you start to your explanations
that sound like this this is my favorite
one that we I hear a lot it was a
networking blip this seems to be the
convenient explanation for almost any
problem is that something went wrong in
the network and it probably won't happen
again
or maybe there was some garbage
collection or then they get increasingly
vague like it was probably just a
one-time thing and usually no one
actually says this but if you take a
step back these explanations often start
to sound like something magic happened
like there's no way we could have
predicted it it probably won't happen
again we probably can't do anything to
prevent it happening again so let's sort
of pretend like it never happened and I
think if there's one thing that you take
away from this talk it should be to keep
an ear out for when you hear these
explanations that sound like magic or
when you're coming up with them yourself
and think about that's usually a sign
that you don't have the tools that you
need to understand what's going
in your system and what I hope to also
convince you of is that a lot of times
these things that look like magic are
actually a really important behavior
that's an indicator of some future
problem or maybe that's actually making
all the performance worse and it's just
particularly exacerbated in this one
case and these things are often worth
actually solving it can also be tempting
to think like maybe I could have solved
this problem if I only had more metrics
and I think there's two problems with
this the first is that these graphs
often end up with a lot of correlation
like this was for a particular outage in
our system where you can see there was
something that weird happened and all of
these graphs but they don't tell you
about causation and so what this often
results in is a scenario where somewhere
between zero and one person and your
organization can look at the set of
metrics and tell you what the root cause
was and everyone else ends up being sort
of stumped the other problem is that it
can exacerbate the temptation to think
about things as magic sometimes you'll
have one metric for each root cause and
it can be tempting to think like Oh a
bunch of smart people thought about the
potential causes for this problem and it
doesn't look like any of them did
actually caused this so therefore it's
probably some cause that I don't
actually care about so I think the
takeaway here is that more what is not
the same thing as why and in fact
answering why often involves getting
less what and sort of honing in on
exactly what the problem was so the key
challenge and answering this why tends
to be reducing the search space so let
me walk through how I did that for this
example again of the slow page load so I
think one common trend when people are
thinking about debugging is that the
debugging process is very iterative
typically you start off with some set of
questions or some set of kind of
hypotheses that go about what might have
gone wrong and the debugging process is
essentially a hypothesis testing project
of walking through each of these
hypotheses to decide whether or not
they're correct so I'll walk through
some of mine you'll see some of them
were right and some of them weren't so
my first guess was maybe the slowness
was happening due to some errors in our
system
I knew that sometimes there were certain
errors that were to occur and that they
might limit the system's throughput so
in this case what I did is I looked up
the latency histogram for the service
that was causing the problem and I
looked for just the cases where they
were
and it's starting to look like there's
actually a bunch of errors that were
happening and so I started to suspect
that this might be the problem
and in this case the thing that helped
me decide whether my hypothesis was
correct or not was getting sufficient
context here what I did is I enabled a
bunch of context about what that
histogram looked like at various times
in the past looking at it from an hour
ago a day ago in a week ago and in this
case what I could see is that these
errors were actually normal
they've been occurring for a while and
this sort of thing is really useful
because if you have a system with even
sort of a little bit of complexity there
are typically kind of infinite many
behaviors that look weird there's a
bunch of weird stuff going on at any
given time and you can't fix all of the
things that look weird when you're
trying to debug a problem so it's really
important to rule out the things that
look weird but actually are normal and
are not the cause of the thing that
you're looking at so here the historical
context helped me realize the slowness
was definitely not due to errors because
these errors are old so the next thing I
started asking is okay I have this
example of something that took 17
seconds can I look at that one example
and understand what about it took so
long so let me take a brief dry version
to talk about with distributed tracing
is Aleta gave a great talk about this
earlier today that you can watch later
if you're interested in a more detailed
explanation but in brief what
distributed tracing is is if you don't
know what distributed tracing as you're
probably familiar with logs where most
of the servers in your system have some
logs and the basic idea of distributed
tracing is to take all of the
information about a particular
transaction so it probably is sprinkled
in a bunch of the logs through a bunch
of the servers and tie them all together
so to trace everything that's involved
in serving a particular request so
distributed tracing will build this tree
of what happened and serving the
requests and tie all those things
together both with some metadata about
what happened and also with some timing
information about what happened so let's
look at a trace from that one example
where things took 17 seconds here what
you're looking at and the trace is the
time is progressing from left to right
then this thing in the middle is showing
me the different services that were
traversed as part of this 17.7 second
page
so at the top we started off in
something called crouton I'm and then at
the end we ended up in the service
called live view each one of the rows
here is showing you a single operation
where the width of the bar is the time
taken now the other thing that's really
useful here and helpful for
understanding the Y is understanding the
critical path there's typically a lot of
things that are happening in parallel it
can be tempting to just look for the
things that took the longest but the
only things that are important are the
things that are actually on the critical
path so here the yellow bar is showing
me the critical path and it's showing
you that it's blocked on listing objects
and here what's important is it's helped
me rule something out I think I probably
would have guessed beforehand that the
thing that was slow was actually reading
these objects in that's happening blow
off the screen where it scrolled off but
the important thing is that that's not
on the critical path the only thing on
the critical path is listing the objects
which is the thing that's low so in this
case we optimize the time to list those
objects and then redeployed the code I
mean here you can see time has advanced
a little bit there's that 17.7 second
one in the middle and I can see that
latency has improved a little bit but it
still hasn't improved enough so I need
to do some other things to improve their
performance so the next thing that I
wanted to do was to hone in on this one
part of the histogram where the results
were slow and again this is where the
histogram can be very helpful because
you can hone in on just that one mode of
behavior that you actually care about
now here what I'd ideally like to see is
some idea of correlation can my tool
tell me what aspects of these things
that were slow is correlated with the
fact that they were slow like what's
different about them than the rest of
the operations unfortunately this was
using light stuff which is the tool
we've built which doesn't do this yet I
actually don't know if any tools that do
this I'm so the way that I tend to do
this is by hand so I clicked on a bunch
of the examples from in this histogram
and a bunch from out of them to try and
understand what's different and in this
case what I figured out was distinct
about these requests that were slow is
that they were coming from some
important customer that one of our
customers was reading a lot more data
and that's why the the the page load for
that customer ended up being a lot more
important and what you can see here is
that that thing that I was really
tempted to explain
is just magic or a networking blip
earlier it's true that it wasn't
something that happened hugely often but
it was something that was happening for
one of our biggest and most important
customers and so it actually is very
important to solve and furthermore was a
leading indicator of more problems this
is one of our customers that has the
most data so if we had ignored this
problem it's something that more and
more customers would have experienced
over time as they send more data into
our system so figuring out the source of
this sort of magic issue ends up being
really important so zooming in on the
critical path to understand what's going
on in this slow example here what I can
see now is that the thing that's slow
it's probably hard to see on the left
side here but on what each of these
things are doing is they're
decompressing and unn marshaling the
data so what slow is just deserializing
the data that it's read into some
internal data structure that we can use
so here the question that I would start
asking is contention there's some shared
resource the CPU that in this case the
request is bottlenecking on and what's
competing for the shared resource is
that actually just this one customer's
request that's important or is it there
that is it the case that there are a
bunch of requests happening at the same
time and they're all competing or is
this one request using too much
parallelism there's a talk from Strange
Loop last year from our CTO spoons that
goes into a lot more depth on sort of
visualization tools that you can
understand this contention but again the
sort of trend here is that there's
something slow and I want to hone in on
what exactly is the root cause of it
like what is contending for this shared
resource so to recap the different
things that we did to answer why the
first thing that was important was again
this freshness and horizon like how
quickly can I get the data about what's
going on to analyze it and then how far
back does it go it was useful to get
data that went sort of a day or a week
or a month back so I could compare it to
see if it was normal then all of the
other things on this score color
scorecard you'll notice are things about
reducing the data so one thing that was
helpful was contacts looking at
historical context to understand if it
was normal another thing that's really
useful is looking at value context like
if you see a value for a particular tag
or attribute of the data that looks
weird can you get some context to
understand whether that was differ
than other normal requests a third thing
that was important is the critical path
helping us rule out a bunch of things
that happen in parallel but didn't
actually matter to the response time of
the request we also talked about
correlation trying to separate out which
of the features of the particular things
that are slow are unique to those
operations and doing this sort of just
in time like my system couldn't
necessarily predict in advance which
requests I wanted to correlate to see
that they are different so can it allow
me to do this sort of just-in-time
analysis and then also contention
thinking about what's responsible for
the use of a shared resource and how can
I use that to speed things up a final
why that I didn't talk about much is
error provenance you'll often see a
scenario where there's some error and
it's important to understand which
upstream service it was talking to this
was something that Lita talked about a
little bit in her talk this morning and
that looking at a distributed trace can
be really helpful for doing when you
have some error for example in front-end
user requests and you don't understand
which of the services involved in that
request caused the error
so just to recap this why you'll notice
that pretty much all of these things are
about reducing the data the thing that
was helpful was not getting more data
but understanding which of the data was
actually important so with this context
I want to take a step back and think
about observability as a whole and
what's the scorecard we should think
about when evaluating different
observability tools so this is the
classic sort of scorecard that I think
folks think about when they're thinking
about how to understand their system
they think of these sort of three
checkboxes metrics logs and distributed
tracing and the mentality is often
something like you know Google and
Facebook understand what's going on with
their micro-service architectures and
they use metrics and logs and
distributed tracing so if we use these
three things we can understand our data
too but I think if you talk to folks who
have all of these things many of them
will still tell you that they have no
idea what's going on with their systems
or that they struggle to debug important
problems if you think about each of
these things these things are really
just data and I think the thing that's
more important to understanding the
system is thinking about the actions
that you do with those data with that
data which is really just two things the
first is measuring systems where you
want a lot more data
and the second is answering why to
understand those systems which is about
reducing the search space and we talked
about a sort of checklist earlier in
this talk for each of these things but
at a high level for measuring symptoms
you want more data and that these high
fidelity latency histograms are really
useful for grouping different behaviors
and then for answering why the thing you
want to do is reduce the search space by
having tools that allow you to eliminate
a bunch of potential hypotheses about
things that might have gone wrong so to
recap this talk I think the first and
most important takeaway is that there's
never any magic in your system only the
absence of good tools and if you think
that there's magic in your system it's
probably because your tools aren't good
enough the second is that logging
metrics and tracing aren't enough to
understand your data you need new kinds
of tools to help you understand
performance that will give you good
measurement latency histograms for
example and that will also allow you to
do refinements so you can reduce the
search debates of why building these
tools is hard and I think an interesting
problem if you're interested working on
that come talk to me more and with that
I'm happy to take any questions and also
feel free to email me if you have
questions offline
[Applause]